Okay,
should be live here. Hello folks.
Let me get Twitch stream set up. I
really need to set like basic background
and stuff, man. That just shows you how
much I hate doing any sort of admin
work.
Like
gh the idea of even having to like set
up basic
socials and Twitch and like all this
stuff annoys me, but whatever. That's
not what today is about. Today is about
jamming some code.
Let's me update the titles here real
quick. Uh update titles.
There we go. There we go.
All right. Here's the idea for today.
RL
in 10,000 lines of code.
That's your idea for today. By the end
of the stream, Puffer Lib is only going
to be 10,000 lines.
Um, I'll tell you a little bit about how
I've gotten very close. We're going to
get the last little cuts done. We'll
finish auditing these 1300 lines
and then we're going to merge a bunch of
contributor PRs and depending on how
long that takes. It's Friday, I might
just play some Net Hack on stream after.
It's still one of our very important
testms and I need to understand more and
more about the uh about that game. At
least that's what I tell myself. Okay.
So, let me first talk about this here.
Let me talk a little bit about this
protein file. Uh if you check the word
counts, right? You can see here this
started at 1790 lines. This was after,
by the way, without much direction. I
already threw uh GPT soul. I threw GPT
soul x high at it. I threw grock at it,
you know, trying to cut it down. The
original PR was like 3500 lines for the
same functionality.
Uh eventually the contributor cut it
down to 2500 and then sort of semi
autonomous um AI cut it down to 1,800
lines and it couldn't reduce it any more
than this. Then from there, me back and
forth in a loop with this thing has I've
cut it down now to only 1300 lines. So
how is it that there is a 500 line
difference, right? Like almost a third
of the code, quarter of the code, um a
third of the code really
difference between what the AI could do
and what I can do. That's a lot of
redundant code. Well, you see,
the LLMs kind of just suck at
programming.
They kind of suck.
So, I mean, I pretty much I just went
through and I was like, well, you have a
million little kernels. I bet you these
should all be combined. And because it's
not a super obvious thing, but like you
can kind of just tell that a this is
longer than it should be. You know, once
it goes and looks at that, oh, it says,
"Oh, yeah. I can make that much
shorter." And then it goes and it tries
it and it ends up making it longer. And
I say, "No, no, no. You did it wrong. do
it this this and this.
What about all these allocations? Why do
we have these? Oh, you need all those
allocations? Yeah. Well, do we have an
upper bound for how much memory this
thing is going to use? Oh, yeah. Of
course we do. So, well, preallocate all
of it. Cool. Now, you can get rid of the
freeze because it's all for the lifetime
of the program. That's minus a whole
bunch of lines of code. What about all
this wrapper for initializing strrus?
Why don't we use C99 strruct initializer
syntax? Really, really basic things.
And it turns out that's the skill.
That's called skill gap. That's it.
Hello, Jess.
Look at this. 10,61 lines.
Let's see what we got left in protein
here.
minus three lines. Two lines. Yeah.
Yeah. Minus three lines.
We'll come back to this.
Do people not indent their switches? Is
this a thing?
You know, actually, no. I see I see the
reason for this.
Would probably do this as if, but it's
not a big deal. Let me see.
I don't really like switch tables. This
is subjective. This is just personal
preference.
I just never really like switch
statements to be honest with you.
I might like it more if I did more
assembly.
Yeah. Yeah. This is just a style thing.
That's not performance sensitive code
whatsoever either, by the way.
I'm pretty sure that um GCC or Clang
would be smart enough to figure that
out. I actually I don't know how um I
know NVCC optimizes stuff a lot less in
places,
but no biggie.
Uh,
does that seem weird to you?
Where did you post it?
Wait, hang on. Was that convert? Yeah,
it's soccer Discord.
There was a big annoying thing in here
apparently.
Did you post something in Jen?
one v one.
Yeah, that's like reasonable enough.
It's very difficult for me to say what
is going to be useful for selfplay
long-term convert. Um, it basically just
it essentially just comes down to
whether or not the end has any sort of
real learnable structure to it
whatsoever
and how it plays with our tests.
But I will definitely take a look at if
you've clean it up. I know in the past a
lot of your PRs I I really haven't spent
enough time taking a look at but it's
it's tough when stuff is very heavily AI
gen because like you see the amount of
time it takes me to actually properly
clean up AI gen code, right?
Like this was an AI port of handwritten
code that a contributor already
attempted to clean up that I now have
down to like half of the length of what
they submitted with the same features
and it's faster.
PRS haven't been AI heavy the M I mean
not the fixes
actually I don't even know how many of
these you have PR I assumed I missed a
couple
It doesn't matter if they're out of
date.
I can still pull stuff in. Also,
sometimes I do pull stuff in. Um,
I do sometimes pull stuff in.
Wait,
isn't this heavily? I remembered you
posting this. I thought this was heavily
AI. This I actually So, this one I
haven't pulled in yet cuz this was going
to be for 50 before I switched 50 and 6.
So, I thought Doug height was very
heavily
AI gen. Oh, did this ever get?
586 is BAT. I thought you explicitly
told me BAT was super heavily AI gen.
If it's not and you want code review,
I'm very happy to like do that.
Which you're most interested in? Well,
how big is the soccer end? Like it it
depends on how big they are, right, man?
clean up. These things just write so
much code, man. It's like I guess how
much code this should take and it just
like multiplies it by three.
I'm actually I'm considering just
releasing like a stupid skill file just
to prevent stuff from this
1,500.
Well, yeah.
I mostly consider the um tests to be
throwaway since they're just LLM gen
tests,
at least when I'm doing stuff,
except for like having a profile or
whatever.
So, to give you an idea, right, I've
been working on this.
I like I can probably publish something
like this eventually. It's just a super
short thing. This actually if you just
apply this in a loop like it gets a lot
of the code jank down and it's not like
prompt ends or anything. It's literally
just like me writing down how I refactor
code.
It just it doesn't know how to do that
on its own.
It isn't. It isn't Jess. It also
increases the amount of time it takes me
to determine whether something is like
AI gen crap or not. This is still very
much a manual process, right? Like I
can't just point it at it and not do any
thinking.
Yeah. But even giving it a reference
end, it doesn't understand the thing
that makes the code good or not.
Uh cr I think they're just bad is all it
is.
The soccer run looks like it would
probably be pretty quick convert. Um
stuff like echolocation is useful if
it's actually somewhat reasonable in
what it's modeling. We have um
not echolocation but electromagnet
magnetism. Um or was it electro
sensitivity? That's the word. Uh there's
a thing that we're cleaning up at the
moment.
Yeah, I know. And like we got it under
one second. It's crazy.
Pathfinder
1,000 artillery
cleaned up. Okay. Bat Pathfinder. I'll
take a look at them then. I'm going to
do PRs in a second actually. Well, not a
second. And as soon as I finish with
this file,
um, I'm mostly just cleaning stuff up
here. We're going to have 10,000 lines
only quite soon. I just have to cut like
I'm 50 lines off now, I think.
I don't understand why it is that it's
just like
it's still can't find basic cleanups.
They uh they are same line. That's just
that's the rapping man.
So this is just this is wrapping. thing.
Walker and better collision solved
instantly.
It's all just out of issues there. I
think there are still a few algo issues,
but it's very close.
There also are still some legitimate
infrastructure issues issues.
Again, very close.
If you push it too hard, it'll just
start golfing. [ __ ]
It's crazy just the amount of structure
clean up.
stupid. Like, it's just Google brain rot
syndrome is what it is.
But like I mean what does that mean
crash? It just means the thing is bad,
right?
Like I don't know. Big tech code is a
specific type of brain damage. I It's
It's very bizarre.
Yeah, I don't know. Writing code by hand
is honestly a lot of fun depending on
the project. Like puffer m are super
chill to just write by hand
because just it's an incredibly
obnoxious metric to like ensure is not
hacked.
It's a very strong signal but like you
can still hack it.
10 10,021 lines. You see that? Just from
me while I was chatting here. That's
minus 40.
So, how is it that this thing can have
gone over at 10 10 different times and
I'm still able to just like very
casually be finding more cuts.
Well, these block comments are
ridiculous. I mean, this we're not
really going to count this as a cut.
But like just speed, that's a major
that's a pretty major consideration,
right?
math PhD at UCLA. I think stuff is
really cool. Applied math. Thanks for
stopping by. Thank you for uh stopping
by. Then we've got
Well, I mean, we're working on stuff
here. It's just very silly in some
sense, right? Because like
you wouldn't have to see me doing all
this back and forth cleanup stuff if
these things just didn't write terrible
code.
Like this is not an issue of me
underspecifying things right or like
being too high level. It's just straight
up you have a very precisely defined
operation that's very cleanly tested
bitwise equivalent with equ with
previous or tested to within numerical
tolerances and it just makes a mess of
the code for no apparent reason.
knobs.
What's this?
Untime.
Unfortunately, we're going to lose a
little bit here because I h I have to
split uh I have to split a few of these
lines. You know, they're just
like just doing a few minutes of rough
like manual work here.
Uh, okay. I see
really don't like this as a language
feature.
You see, I don't like that it just you
indent all your code an extra level and
then all you do is like you're trying to
preserve name space, but like you should
just have unique names and often times
you're preventing yourself from reusing
stuff that you can just reuse anyways.
Sometimes like the stuff just looks
incredibly stupid what I'm doing here
because it's like you know you can't
possibly be worth this amount of time to
refactor like just like this right but
it it really is unfortunately
like even basic stuff like what on earth
is like why does it do this right it
just cuts stuff I don't know who ever
came up with the idea that you should
cut lines to like match the opening
parentheses
like what is this All right.
It's possible we end up with um a few
additional lines after this, but it's
spurious, right?
Like I guess one other way of viewing
this
See what we got here.
Anything?
Have a couple little comments.
I don't think we really need these. Dash
dash. Does it add anything? No.
We're almost
almost to the point.
This is like almost to like baseline.
Okay. I only see like one or two major
style things.
Super indented crap.
But at least I don't see anything here
where just like just basically looking
at the code it's like oh yeah this is
like why the hell would you even ever do
that right? Like there's some logic in
here that needs to be but then the file
ends like thankfully it ends.
Damn it. We're back to 45. Okay. Well,
there's some spacing required, I guess.
They actually just can't for some of the
stuff we do cuz like I mean 100x slower
it's like the point of it is the speed
like puffer li but 100 times slower is
not useful
though actually that's kind of funny
because 100x lower is still on the high
end of um other RL libraries.
50 million divide by 100 still 500 kPS
per GPU with perfect multiGPU scaling.
Uh yeah, I've eaten too. I've eaten
enough ramen for one lifetime, though.
tens of megabytes.
Tiny.
Worst case, very tiny. Cool.
Okay. 10034. I think that's reasonable.
Um, I could continue to improve
the protein code
for sure.
But I think without getting into the
individual
like the math again which is a bigger
project. I think at least now this is
like usable code, right?
So last 34 lines can come out of um
upper end or whatever.
Let's see how much fat there's.
Algo's clean. Puffel's pretty clean.
Well, we can get rid of that because we
know we're not keeping that [ __ ]
would be better, right?
Input output batch size.
Yeah, that's good.
I'm just cut a little bit of stuff from
here.
These are easy cuts.
else in here that's like dumb?
Reu.
Bunch of path stuff that we should clean
up, but other than that, it's good.
So there you go folks. CPU eval path. Uh
best CUDA train path in the world by
like over an order of magnitude more
like two.
So architecture, our own hyperparameter
sweep, our own logging, our own
dashboard, basically the entire damac
from scratch or at least from CUDA up
and uh that's all that's all it takes.
Jess uh CPU training has dropped
entirely.
We kept CPU evaluation and we actually
made CPU evaluation better. It is not
realistic for me to maintain a CPU train
path. I considered it quite heavily.
If it's going to be an entire separate
train path, it's not worth it. Okay, I I
changed some seating stuff here. There
you go. It's It's good.
That feels good, man. That's a big
accomplishment.
Big win.
Really big win, man. Really, really big
win.
learner perf. How much work went into
learner performance?
The learner throughput then the end. Oh,
a huge amount of work went into every
layer of the stack, man. It's the entire
thing is ground up in very heavily
optimized CUDA down to the microcond in
most places.
It's not under a minute. It's under a
second.
You see
like that literally that was the train
time. Boom. Trained
ID valve for you it for you as well. But
this is on our remote machine. We still
have some testing to do with it and
such, but
there you go.
Uh,
I know I can SCP the model.
Hang on. I still like this the stage is
still dirty.
I'm trying to think if it makes sense.
How do I make sense of what's going on
here? You kind of hang out for a while.
Should I make an informative?
We might we might add something back
here, but I think this is fine for Now,
I think we are going to end up putting
this back.
We are end up going to end up putting
like a thousand lines of it back just
for like um like learning purposes type
thing. Maybe
I don't think we need it in here.
It'll be like no selfplay.
Um just like not even priority just like
the simplest possible
thing that we could do I would imagine
if that
in the Python version Jess you don't
need it
right
I just want to take a moment because my
local's very messy there. I want to take
a moment to appreciate
the 5C branch.
Still has a bunch of random [ __ ] in
it. But um
Robbo code. Hey. Yeah, that's exactly uh
that's exactly where it's from. That was
one of my first exposures to it as well.
If you look at that repo, like you can
kind of tell that that poisoned a
generation of programmers. They have
like hundreds of files, tens of
thousands of lines of code, horrendous
crazy APIs. It's like a few hundred
lines in C. Runs 10,000 times faster. We
train it with our stack at like 100
million steps per second.
We're beating some of their best
scripted policies already, even without
training against them directly.
It's actually one of our best
environments for selfplay research
here. I'll show you in a second, though.
We don't have the uh the web demo
updated to the latest version where we
actually have like good bots and stuff,
but I'll show you. Um if you just go to
like puffer.ai AI.
We have all our demos on here. Does this
look familiar?
You can actually like Well, it's not
meant to be human played, but this is me
now controlling the blue one trying to
like aim and I take my hands off and
then the uh well, this is just some
stupid scripted bot, but we have some
really good networks that play it. So,
yeah, we have all sorts of projects like
this. It's pretty easy to get involved,
honestly. Like it's useful to have an RL
background, but we have a ton of people
that came in with zero AI experience.
Like frankly, it's way harder to teach
people the system stuff than it is to
teach them at least enough to get
started with the uh the AI component.
Like systems is just tough, right, to
teach people. This is like the drone end
from our intern.
This is starting to feel like a real
release.
You know,
that's all that's in here.
This is source.
This is going to be 0% Python.
Literally zero Python.
Really simple ML.
Yeah. Yeah, I remember that.
I remember I basically had no idea what
I was doing. So instead of actually
implementing a good bot, I just like use
the debug drawing mode to just spam draw
stuff all over the place
so that when you would like run the bot,
it would just like blow everything up.
[laughter]
I'm going to say we're going to uh cap
this at another half hour though, only
another half hour maximum that I will
spend on cleaning this stuff up and then
we're going to do some PR reviews. I owe
Muffin at least a good half hour, 40
minute review, I'd say, depending on how
much Cody has. And um we'll merge some
other stuff as well.
Yeah, I'm going to just let it do this
and I'm going to diff like we're just
going to assume this will take me
another half hour. It's fine. I just
want to make sure it doesn't slip
anything in. We'll just diff the M's one
by one and it'll be fine.
We'll just diff the M's one by one. Like
cuz basically the thing is this should
only really be modifying like a few
lines per file to add some macros at the
top.
Um, but if it starts slipping other crap
in, like we're not going to let it
destroy our nice
Now would be a great a great time to
take a quick break for restroom while we
get the initial pass on this and then
the uh the schedule for the rest of
today
will be
uh half an hour a little less than half
an hour now on cleaning up ends. So we
just have a nice clean 5C to start from.
Uh, I'll just make sure nothing gets
screwed up in the process of doing this.
Convert, what the [ __ ] are you talking
about? Um, and then we will merge a
bunch of PRs in
and we will continue from there. So, I
will be right Back.
Well, it is still running,
but that's kind of okay. It's uh it's
doing a lot of like really dumb [ __ ]
work on um a lot of files. That's fine.
We will
we're going to have to go through a lot
of ends actually. Oh man, it's going to
be so cool though now with how fast
everything is. If we can just get oursel
like a reasonable set of default params,
we're going to be able to just crush
pretty much everything.
I mean, we can now start doing like we
can start thinking about thousand
experiment sweeps in an hour on one GPU.
Hello, Valo. I am about to start doing
big PR merges. I have something to show
you.
That's Puffer Lib. All of it.
That's the entirety of Puffer LIIB right
there.
What's fast right now?
Um
I think it's building [ __ ] in the
background, so this might get messed up,
but we'll see.
It's a lot of end code Jess. Oh, Glitzy.
Hey, Glitzy.
What do you think about the size of
protein here?
Holy [ __ ] I'm telling you, man. These
LLMs just write [ __ ] terrible code.
[laughter]
Takes me a while to figure out how to
get it cleaned up, but
it's pretty simple ultimately.
Here, I'll show you.
It's actually It's live on the 5C branch
already.
Here's your space logic. Here your
little device helpers. Here is your
matern kernel.
Here's your entire matern thing all
fused together instead of being 10
little tiny kernels.
You'll notice that the GP has way less
bookkeeping and crap with Alex. It's all
uh upfront memory allocations.
There probably still some things I could
like inline and merge. Here's your train
for the GP. All one big function.
Here's your sampling.
Here's the big strct for sweeps.
All your allocations are all up front.
Here's your observe function. Again,
it's kind of all been consolidated.
Sweep stop thing.
Some noise stuff. Probably more to
merge. all the KD stuff as well down
here.
And uh here's the suggest function.
Again, it's just like clean up,
compress.
There you go. Cost model fitting. This
stuff here is pretty deeply indented. I
could probably even clean that up more.
Here's the search center stuff. Target
cost sampling and the success classifier
argmax. And that's it. That's the whole
file.
thoughts on robotics.
You know, actually there was a really
cool robotics thing earlier today. Like
when I think of robotics, I I really
don't get that exc that excited except
for stuff like this. In my mind, this is
infinitely more exciting to me than
humanoids.
working on a robot and I wanted to get
in to it. Yeah. Yeah, that's the type of
stuff I'm excited about in robotics,
frankly. I guess, you know, 60F arms,
like robot arms, like constrained ones,
those are also interesting to me. Um, if
you can get them just going super fast,
you know, whatever. But having to do
stuff from vision, it's just gh
annoying.
We just like mute. Not interested. I
like get the politics off my stupid
timeline. Just show cool stuff.
We still going here.
Yeah, we're still going. Seven Ms are
done. Apparently,
I'm going to have to audit this real
quick while I'm still in the mindset for
it, but then I'm going to start on um I
guess I can start sort of triaging PRs
in the meantime, right?
Why? That doesn't look very AGIish.
Well, but that's the thing, right? Like
um
know people are selling you a really
dumb version of the future. If you think
about humanoids for two seconds, it's
like really dumb.
Like we should have specialized
machines for everything that we can just
like design, prototype and actually
manufacture specialized machinery for
every individual application that will
be dramatically more efficient than just
scaling humanoids stupidly.
It's incredibly obvious to me.
Okay, this one. I got to do this one
today because I promised Muffin this.
Uh, where's Volen?
Oh, this is going to be a fun one.
This is one where I kind of just play
with it. Unless Volo, is there specific
chunks of code that I can review here? I
guess I have you here so I can like we
can go through this.
combine harvester for everything.
Exactly.
At least eventually it will, right? We
might have an intermediate period where
VCs like fund the massive scaling of
really stupid general purpose hardware
and then if we spend, you know, uh a
trillion dollars to make humanoid robots
work, maybe then we'll use those to like
very inefficiently work our way towards
more specialized stuff. But the
specialized stuff will happen
eventually. It should be happening now,
but unfortunately like Silicon Valley is
mostly all hot air. So
things are not always being made for
like sound technical reasons
encoder.
We'll talk about colo encoder.
Let's take a look.
Jesus Christ, man.
Holy
plus 88,000 lines.
Is this the model?
What's inc?
I don't even know what this extension
is.
Is this the
Jesus
Well, I mean, this is still going to be
awesome.
Is there anything in here I need to be
worried about? Like I can't even look at
it in this UI.
Um, merge conflicts.
Are there edits to the algo and ocean in
this?
All the way to the bottom is core. I
don't even think I can scroll to the
bottom. Can I
think their their UI will break, right?
Oh, no. Okay.
So,
gotcha.
I gotcha. This is fine.
Humans decide what to build. Who is the
engineer? The AI is.
But uh cap uh was it cal first? Yeah, we
have way like that's not what's
happening here.
Okay. Arguably with well cuz Ko is a
straight port first of all and then most
of the work with Ko is like the
observation and data modeling right
5C can rebase tomorrow. I can probably
just get this thing pulled in right now.
Well, as soon as I finish this,
can be the project manager. If you don't
have deep technical experience, you just
don't need that. Like the thing is most
human project managers are absolutely
[ __ ] worthless. So don't delude
yourself into thinking that you're
adding value when you have no technical
ability whatsoever.
I think it it's actually the case now
that you need even deeper technical
knowledge than before because otherwise
these language models are just very good
at making a mess quicker. like they make
a mess at superhuman rates. That's for
sure.
Like don't delude yourself people into
thinking that there's like oh using LLMs
is a skill and like you just need like
training and then you'll have value on
it's just it's all lies.
like you either know what's going on um
at the level of line by line code, at
the level of systems, at the level of
modeling and all the things that can go
wrong
and you're very heavily steering
everything
and manually checking things very often.
Uh or you're just not and then you're
just, you know, deliluding yourself into
thinking you're doing something.
Like in this case here, even though
there's a lot of AI gen code, like
um so Volo is both experienced in
systems, but he also has he's also like
a top 1% Runescape player. So he's able
to very quickly assess when things are
wrong and then go figure out why. Um,
and then a lot of the work here is in
modeling observations and actions and
stuff which the model like the LMS can't
remotely do.
It's yeah, the the skill issue thing is
just that's just cope. There's no
there's absolutely no skill involved in
using language models whatsoever. like
the workflow changes that are introduced
by language models are just immediately
obvious to anybody that has uh a good
programming background.
And then like the learning curve thing
is just people who don't have a
programming background diluting
themselves into thinking that they're
learning things, but really they're kind
of just like
they're just going in circles doing
nothing.
like here, even though this looks like a
massive amount of like the LLM's been
spinning here with a bunch of random sub
agents for like 10 minutes, right?
It's almost done. And I'll show you
exactly what was changed and you'll see
how the changes here are actually very
precisely described things that don't
have like there's no subtlety or there's
no like LM making decisions. It's
entirely mechanical. It's obviously it's
outside of the realm of what you could
do with just um like an IDE find
replace. It's a little bit fuzzier than
that, but it's still entirely
mechanical.
You'll see that in a second. And then
we'll go over that real quick and we'll
start merging some stuff. Um, where's
this encoder, by the way? Is it in
Ocean?
I should just look at this.
Oh, here it is. Okay, so we have entity
encoder. Okay, so this is you grabbing
the entity encoder. Cool. You grab the
NPCs.
Couple random gelloos
Oh, inventory. Okay.
Uh, fused pool.
I don't know what this fused pool is.
Do you have the architecture for this
thing?
Uh here I'll get the Discord open. Volo
if you just type in dev or general or
whatever. I'll just I'll put this on
screen. But um
so
this is some variant of the entity
encoder it would appear
I don't know what specifically the
entity encoder architecture you have is
here.
Used grad. Okay. So it's
these are not just like trivial kernels.
I probably this is some variant of based
off entity encoder.
But hang on. Where is Okay, here we go.
Entity encoder forward.
kind of weird.
I found the right spot. I I'd like a
description of the architecture real
quick to map this.
Okay,
that was the longest Gro has ever had to
uh do anything.
Check a few of these
long or Then
Yeah, Gra has been very nice.
I mean, I say that it did just work for
like 20 minutes, but I just had it go
through like 50 different ends in
puffer. So,
Oh, it's I think it's much more than 30k
lines, Jess.
I would think some of those ends are
very long.
Yeah, we don't really care too much
about horizontal bloat in puffer, right?
Like if there a bunch of ends and some
of them are too long or whatever, it's
fine because like realistically I'm just
going to periodically go through ends
and we'll end up using whichever ones
are currently the highest quality and
currently the most useful for research.
So that's why like submitting a really
good end means that you're contributing
a lot to our research because it will
just go right to the top of the things
that we use. Know 2048 was a super
useful PR. All the cleanup work on that
was the maze end was great. Um, Breakout
original was awesome, All right.
Um, Glitzy, it's not that I want more
stuff on molecular applications as much
as it is that uh I think that once
Puffer is like set up like that's where
Puffer is going, right? is going to be
into solving hard problems in actual
science
um rather than just games. However, I
don't think that scientific problems are
a good benchmark because they're less
interpretable. So, in my mind, games are
going to remain the best task for
benchmarking and for algorithm research.
And then the scientific sim, those are
like applications, right, that we want
to solve with Puffer.
Sure
thing, Jess. Oh, and by the way, if you
submit an end like that and we get
clients based on it, like you're going
on the contract.
Pretty simple.
So, that's also how you get professional
stuff with us.
you want
Doom sending? It's pretty much finished.
Uh, depends how good it is, man. Like,
cuz I I'm a little confused what you
did. Like, did you rewrite Doom? Cuz
Doom is like the original is written in
high performance C, I believe, isn't it?
So, like what did you do?
What are some M's that are most likely
to get contracts?
Just any reasonably defined RL
application in areas where there are
like people in industry doing that stuff
um and it's making them money, right?
There's all sorts of stuff in logistics,
there's stuff in robotics. Um scientific
sim is harder. I think that's longer
term where we want to go though it's
it's a little bit fiddlier to get direct
stuff on that. Um drone stuff. Yes.
Though again there has to be like if you
do one part of a sim right and it's not
as easy as like an obvious sell to
people that's a little tougher.
I mean ultimately like if you really
really want to do professional stuff
with us, right? It's um it's better to
both do the sim and then also start
doing like some promo and some outreach
and you know once you've submitted stuff
to us that's like you know actually
integrates well and is of high quality,
we're also happy to help promote and to
help with uh with that sort of stuff
since we do this stuff professionally
all the time.
I should also mention it's uh it's quite
a good split on the uh the actual
professional work. It's not like you
just get some tiny commission for doing
all the work.
Contracts, at least contracts where it's
like puffer and one person tend to be
50/50.
But Jess, I think it's that it's not
that it can be made fast. I think Doom
literally just already is very fast. Um
I think it's a little tied to the
rendering a little bit. Like you
probably have to decouple a couple
things, but I'm not entirely sure. I'd
have to look at the at FBR's project and
see what he's exactly done.
Let's see what we have now.
Way better, right?
I mean, you absolutely don't have to be
able to do pixels to be able to do
valuable stuff in RL. That's mostly a uh
conceit
of uh research.
I think we'll just commit all this right
now so I have a a clean time stamp and
we'll just say like, you know, I'm going
to have to I still have to go through
all the M's obviously and that's going
to be part of the experimental work.
So, I think we'll leave that on the the
todos.
stuff cut out for better perf
and logic has
Yeah, I mean I think that in your case
since I know you do a lot of AI stuff
with it, like if you can get some
reasonable looking policies running um
with either, you know, whichever port
that you have, I think that would be
enough for us to want to merge stuff and
use it for sure,
particularly if it doesn't put any major
pressure on our core. You know, we're
generally pretty open to merging
whatever ends
Oh yeah, Clifford PR. I uh I'm going to
pull that in as well. Man, I gota I
think next week will probably be the
week I pull in a lot of ends.
We have a few little algorithm things to
test left, but other than that, it's
mostly just like getting puffer uh
ripping on all the ends and seeing what
we can do.
Y self play on publish five pretty much
Jess
I don't know where I haven't heard from
Spencer I think Spencer's getting some
rest he did a lot lot of client work
last few weeks.
reward function cheats or spam kills.
I ran around
rounding up.
Wait. Rounding up all the You did not
make the enemies puffers, my guy. If you
made a puffer shooting version of Doom,
I'm not going to be happy with that.
[laughter]
You can make the bullets puffers or
something if you want.
are carrots.
Yeah, the enemies are just Japanese
chefs, I guess.
Okay. Okay, we do these just initial
silly things and then um
yeah, we go we do the initial silly
thing and then we're going to basically
just fix the M one by one as we need.
Sprinted to the exit dodging.
We'll do this and then we're going to
start merging PRs.
Okay.
Kind of slow.
to do pong in um
375 ms in my mind, but it works,
you
Okay, 172 files changed,
5.3K deletions, 4.9K insertions,
and all the binding files are gone, by
the way. That's intentional.
What are you testing on?
And we have
welcome, welcome, folks.
Uh, so currently we're just cleaning up
the 50
port.
I just finished. I don't know if we're
going to say finished, but I'm like I'm
happy with the the milestone that we
hit. We got the code under 10k lines.
It's pretty tight. I think that if I
spent another like full two weeks
on the code.
Um, and you know, I would I was being
serious about not trying to golf it. I I
doubt I'd be able to clear more than
another few hundred lines. So, it's
pretty good.
Oh, let's see. Let's see what uh what
result we got from this.
Why is this just a big open room?
Why are the enemies puffers?
Wait, dude. What is this?
This is not how Doom levels work. And
why? I I just would like to know what on
earth possibly possessed you to make the
enemies the puffers.
[laughter]
Like, get out. Come back when you have
an end where you're not shooting puffer
fish.
Holy crap. From the uh the protein
refactor. I mean, I'm going to be honest
with you. I mostly did that this
morning, man.
It's just actually the case that the
LLMs are that bad. I don't know what to
tell you.
They're very nice.
Let us
Oops. Let's not do this. Let's do like
this.
Okay, we'll pull Valo's one in first
real quick. Did Valo write anything?
He is writing something.
And uh I owe Muffin a
review.
I don't want to start muffins review
though until um
Oh jeez.
We'll take a while. Yeah. I don't want
to start until I know I'm going to be
able to just like do this straight.
small PR def.
Uh, well, Valos is 80,000 lines. So,
I just want to see where the bulk of
this is. Little binding file, little
readme.
C demo is about the right size. Okay. It
actually is.
It actually is here.
Oh, wait. He actually made all the
assets as well. Yo, that's cool,
Wait.
Yo, this is really nice.
Um,
okay.
700 lines of this. 800 lines of this are
test.
And then we have
Depending on how complex the game is,
that could be reasonable. Let's actually
watch the game first.
Interesting. The projectiles die
if the thing that they're killing, I
guess, expires early.
Okay.
demo.
That's very cool.
So,
I'm just seeing if I see any crazy AI
gen crap real quick.
I'm going to go I'm obviously this is
not the review. I'm going through in
detail in a bit.
This is just me scrolling real quick.
Yeah. Okay. I This is There's some AI.
No programmer born this millennium
writes this,
but I'm going to trust that Muffin is
doing um quite a bit manually here. So,
I will give this a full review.
lots of really shitty defensive
programming. Um things that are
anacronistic like you know a guy you
know is 20 is writing stuff that's
nobody's done since the 70s.
like relatively basic stuff mixed with
like just really advanced things that
obviously a person would not know about
The thing that's very difficult to know
is like the precise if they if they
wrote it and they used some AI, right?
uh the precise level of effort
that is pretty tough to know without
knowing the person.
Is AI able to write good C code if you
just have it write C with no guidance?
Absolutely not. I literally have spent
the last like week and a half
refactoring shitty LLMC and CUDA
and I was able to cut about 3,000 lines
off of our source, which is like a third
of the project size.
cool.
We have these
I actually am thinking of doing that.
Jess,
the thing is they don't really do enough
on their own.
You still have to know what you're
doing.
32 million params, huh?
Yeah. Okay. Volo
is this Did Vall reply? No. Where'd he
go?
What am I doing? What are these projects
and why are you reviewing them? So, I
developed the highest performance
reinforcement learning library in
existence.
This is Puffer Lib. We have a bunch of
fun demos on the website. A lot of them
are games. Games are best for research.
got drones, we've got a driving sim,
we've got some other stuff in here as
well. You can train tiny superhuman
agents in seconds. We can push up to 50
million step per second training with uh
numbers above 10 million being realistic
for most projects on a single GPU. We
can push over 100 mil step per second
training on a single HGPU node.
And we have our whole stack for custom
simulation
training,
state-of-the-art model architecture,
automated hyperparam optimization, large
scale experiment visualization.
Sorry, the puffer. What network is this
use? This thing here. I think this is
just a massive encoder strapped to a big
mining group. Obviously, I'm not going
to let this thing finish, but Valo says
he's got a new config tomorrow. Let's
take a look.
Yeah. So, this is two layers with 2048
hidden size.
actually here a really good way if you
just want to know like how um how fast
his his thing is. If I just set this
thing to 16 real quick.
So you can see how heavily bottlenecked
this is.
accepting projects that people did.
Yeah, it's all open. This is all open
source.
Uh I know that this can go way faster
than 40k.
And it's not the ob size that's
bottlenecking it either. I think it is
just straight up the end of speed.
And this is with 32k 32 threads and
everything.
But yeah, there's definitely
it's definitely sweeps.
This looks like a lot of code. Yeah, but
do you know what this is?
If you look up like this, so this this
trainer here.
Okay, look at this. So this trainer
here,
so it's this boss fight first of all
with this dude where it's like this.
Oops. I forget the [ __ ] boss.
Yeah. So, this boss fight here.
Oops, I'm bad. I for I literally forget
the boss.
Oops, I'm dead. Yeah, one tick late. But
so it's this boss fight with a bunch of
stuff, but then there's like waves of
enemies leading up to this thing that
are very complicated with a whole arena
and they all have their own mechanics.
It's a pretty big thing. Now, do I think
it's ADK lines big? No, especially not
if you're sharing the engine. But do I
believe that if you're like trying to AI
port stuff that it will produce 80k
lines? Yeah.
Not obvious. It's very slow anymore.
It's not obvious that it's very slow
anymore.
Well, wait, Valla, where's the compute
going then?
Like, what does it have to update on
every tick?
Like the only thing I could think of is
you're getting massively screwed by
pathing. thing.
see a port of Bellatro.
[laughter]
Depends how good the port is.
I mean, go ahead and uh like hook it up.
Let's see if you have it decent. We'll
take a PR.
Obviously, if you're using the original
games assets, those have to be a
separate download. If you're using like
your own assets, um, then it's fine to
include them. Is
movement forecast, BFS pathing, and gear
setup oracles.
gear setup oracles
two 28 slot honest inventory.
Okay. So, we basically I need to
understand what you're doing here then
for those things to be slow
typically we like it when our ends have
like some sort of at least minimal
self-contained renderer.
Makes it a lot easier for us to showcase
work
on the fly a lot.
Yeah, but Volo, in my mind, like that's
scaffolding, isn't it? The agent should
be able to learn all that crap.
So, if the training wheels are
expensive, like fine, but then in my
mind, it's not like, oh, well, the
long-term thing is we want to give it as
many training wheels as possible. It
should be like the training wheels
should give us a baseline that this
thing works given access to this
information. Okay, why can't it learn
this? Oh, oops. We forgot to give it
this other piece of information in the
obs that it would need to compute that,
right?
SIM is 2% of MSTEP. OBS construction is
98%.
Okay. Yeah.
I mean, that's definitely something to
look at then for sure
cuz here's Inferno at 270K, right? This
is more reasonable.
Yeah, but the thing is like
Volo, I don't care if it learns it in a
100 mil steps.
Like if it can just figure it out in a
billion, but it's faster wall clock,
whatever. Or decent wall clock, like
whatever.
So basically every single game ever that
we put our RL agents on, they're at a
huge disadvantage compared to humans
because the games like they're made so
that you know what to look like know
what to do by looking at them or at
least you can read some instructions and
know what to do.
The agents always have to figure
everything out anyways.
So I actually I think that the training
wheel thing that you have is good uh as
a baseline. So like let's say you if you
have it solved with those like we can
ablate out that information and ablate
in cheaper things.
Forecast versus off.
Yeah.
I'm not saying like that you need to PR
this without the training wheels to be
clear. I think that that's good, but
like you should essentially use this as
the baseline of what it takes to solve
this end now and then figure out bit by
bit, right? Like how much each of these
pieces of information matter and if you
can give it something that's like less
training wheelie, right?
Sim and obs for the Yeah, exactly.
Again, that's not bad. like what you're
doing now. This is how you end up
solving really hard technical problems
like this. Um,
you know, it very well might be that
there are a couple algorithmic
limitations with puffer still that make
certain parts of this problem hard or it
could end up being like a pure obs
limitation or something like that,
right? And going through that process,
that's how like that is the valuable
thing to puffer, right? That is how we
advance the project is by solving these
hard problems and then seeing to what
extent it's a modeling issue in the
problem versus things need to change in
core puffer to make it work.
But yeah, there you go. So inferno here,
this this works very nicely, right? Or
well, it doesn't win yet, but uh
hopefully it wins in four minutes. I
don't know. We'll see. Either way, I'm
going to use a rest room. We'll merge
this in fully so at least we have at
least we have a stable version of both
of these in Puffer 5C which is very
nice. And then uh we will do it's 2:40
p.m. we will do Muffin's full review.
We'll do Muffin's full review for his
tower defense end and merge that in.
I will be right back. We'll be right
back. For anybody who's new around here,
by the way, um please take a moment to
star the repository on GitHub. all open
source work and uh doing that really
really does help us out quite a lot.
I'll be right back and then we'll do uh
we'll do this PR review.
Okay,
we're back
on this for months at this point. Wait,
is worth simpler version we work field
training wheels way more stuff than I
can write about on this for months at
this point?
Yeah, man. If you want to jam in a
Discord call at some point on or off
stream and just like go through for a
bunch of hours and see if we can figure
out some stuff with the training wheels,
I'm more than happy to do that.
I think pretty much like I'm going to
commit this merge right now, but like
make sure you just train a a decent
baseline policy on 5C. Make sure I
didn't break anything of yours in the
process of doing this. And uh then we
will be able to and we'll pretty much
just be able to start going through
And
we can run I can suggest some ablations
to run. I can tell you like sanity check
some of the data stuff. Um obviously
like bits of the code are pretty bloated
for me to be able to just like look at
the encoder and tell you if anything's
right
from the bat. Um so we have to go
through that a little bit more detail.
I'm more than happy to do that. Like
this is in my mind this is one of the
top Ms that I care about for uh for
research for like 50 and beyond.
and we'll see if I can do any of the
like Joseph figures out problem in five
minutes thing. [laughter]
do this on stream. If follow wants to do
that call on stream, I'm happy to do
that on stream. If he wants to do it off
stream, we can do it off stream.
I'm happy to work with contributors and
it's, you know, if people are
comfortable doing it on stream, it's
cool by me. If not, no worries.
It was pretty cool though.
Um, this does not win out of the box, by
the way. I don't know why. So, it's
possible there's um I don't know if this
Inferno config is supposed to win out of
the box or not.
If so, then we're going to have to track
down some discrepancies.
U this to go. This is just eval running
now away.
Uhoh. Um, wait.
Is this
which directories should I have should I
not include
with the PR?
It's not in the get ignore
with the gear switches. You mean I
guess? No, we'll sort that out easily,
man.
That's just going to be like action
space modeling junk.
Oh, okay. Okay, so this was this 80,000
line PR is just is like the entire
Wait, this is too short for this to
possibly be.
So I'm guessing that there is Ko stuff
in the original.
Ah, I see. Okay.
Yeah, there's a lot of stuff.
and we're going to do muffins review
next. Let me know when's a good time as
well, Volo, for uh like a work session.
I'm on California time for the time
being, but you know, I know it's late
for you. like let's let's figure let's
figure out a good time like just let me
know on Discord when we can jam a work
session on this, right?
Okay, massive, massive pushes.
Now we will start Muffins. If there's
nothing else I want to fully focus on on
Muffins review since he spent I think
quite a good amount of time on this end
and like at least a good few months I've
been seeing this.
Anybody wants to time stamp this? 242
into the uh the stream apparently.
So we are going to
first time contributor.
all changes.
Where's this?
Restart a review.
is fine. Pretty normal config.
Uh Muffin is not here. I will go back
through it with him if he is here, but I
said I would do it today and I have uh
this is when I've got some time to do
it. I'm of course I'll go back through
it with him as well. I want to get an
initial review on this though. He
doesn't drop by the stream too often.
review
TD config? Egg
error.
Kind of weird.
Get finite double.
Okay. I was I didn't see this when I was
like LLM.
already the first 50 lines. So, yeah.
already.
I actually think I'm going to use this
end to test the stupid skill file I was
writing.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, look at this. He's probably right
about this. [laughter]
It's funny.
All right, let's get back to muffin.
Okay, I'm sorry. I got to stay on task
here. Uh, log file is fine.
Okay. Now, where is
tower defensec?
l is lines of code.
Um the reason so lines of code like the
length of your program it's not
perfectly correlated with code quality
but of all the metrics out there it is
the best correlated.
So in general if you're not golfing your
code making it shorter is almost always
an improvement.
What do you prefer the best way to keep
determinism? Grand R dude.
Grand R is fine.
Um,
Slightly annoying,
I'd say, but fine.
I'm not going to ding him on this. Like
realistically, we should probably
eventually at some point just stick mass
sampling into um
puffer uh puffer CPU whatever.
Too many abstraction layers. A bad
pattern. Yes. Uh the default number of
abstraction layers that you want is
zero.
And then uh
yeah, reasonable
reasonable standard. Um
well,
okay,
that's a lot of comments for just the
binding files and the demo file. Let's
see.
What do we got?
Yeah, basically it when people default
to like big tech style heavily
abstracted code um they will find that
in their first PR I kind of just shred
it and like end up making it 10x faster.
and a third of the length.
And then you'll basically you'll compare
your original code and then you'll
compare my refactor and be like, "Oh
yeah, that's way easier."
And then you just question like why the
hell this abstracted rapper [ __ ]
exists in the first place. And um if it
has any use, definitely doesn't have any
here.
Yeah. So, there's nothing really wrong
with this other than Um,
for deck.
Uh I prefer not to have forward decks,
but it's semi-justified for client
typically.
Could use a ve too, but I'm never going
to ding somebody for not splitting stuff
out, so this is fine. I'm all
AI generated code in PRs. I mean,
there's tons of it in here, so it
depends. If you submit some awful
garbage to the core of Puffer, like,
yeah, you're just going to get flamed.
Um,
if you're submitting heavily AI gen code
to like environment stuff,
it depends if you're upfront about it.
If you try to make like a midsize
project that's supposed to be clean,
then I'm kind of just going to go, hey,
look at all the places you could improve
this code and make this better. Um, I'm
also I'm trusting that Muffin has done a
lot of this manually and he's kind of
just let some defensive stuff slip in
because if it's fully AI gen, it's
incredibly rude to ask me to spend my
time reviewing something that you
yourself have not put any substantial
time into making. Um,
for longer stuff like Valo's Runescape
environment, like that's an 80,000line
port, obviously a lot of that is going
to be AI gen, and it's mostly going to
be about
uh performance controls, making sure
models are not injecting a bunch of
bloat into at least the performance
level, verifying that the thing is
correct versus the original, since it's
a port, it's not an original, uh,
modeling of observations, and so on and
so forth.
So, like it depends, but if you're doing
something that is demonstrating lack of
common sense, you'll be made very
quickly aware of it.
I also It's like I spend a lot of time
cleaning up AI gen crap as is. It's so
exhausting. It really is so exhausting.
I mean, basically the last week and a
half of my life has just been like like
fixing LLM jank in core code, which has
just not been fun. I mean, the result is
very good and it's like it's nice, but
holy hell.
Okay, let me see what his strs are here
because I actually I want to figure this
out. So, tower
Uh, okay. I can't say that this is bad
yet,
but we will see.
good. I like this
TD max enemies. Where are we at? 250.
Let's see what his constants are to see
how much stuff he has on the stack.
Oops. Let's see how much stuff he put on
the stack here. So, max enemies.
TD recursive. Oh, that's a lot. Wait,
950.
That might be putting a lot on the
stack.
I'm not going to ding him for this,
though. If he's not smashing it, like,
it's fine. I think this is it's it's a
lot on this deck, but whatever.
Okay. PXY
X. Fine.
I think that's just enemies.
The max projectiles I think looked
small. I'll have to say
site buildable for kind.
We don't use clang format. So that's a
little odd.
Double of float of double of state.
Yeah,
I don't know why we're doing our own
RNG.
It's possible that this thing does
consume a lot of RNG to be fair.
I get suspicious when I see a lot of
little functions
compacting a entity pool.
Uh realloc.
very very rarely need to be calicking in
your uh well after a net.
You can use whatever you want for dev. I
forget what our build script does. Like
this is going to get compiled by NVCC
anyways in Puffer 5.
Tower stats.
Wait, TD tower stats. This is a void
function. What does this do?
Well, this is a kind of a crazy wrapper,
right?
float.
I That's crazy. There's basically no
reason to ever do this.
Uh, Rob, I don't use the models enough,
like the all the different models enough
to know or care about their specific
idiosyncrasies.
Like,
this is why you don't see me getting
super excited for the next model. Cuz in
my mind, like, yeah, I use them and
they're useful tools, but they're all
dumb. They all do dumb things. and I
don't notice one particularly being far
less dumb than the other. The main thing
I notice, frankly, is how slow they are,
which is why I've been using Grock for
everything for the last couple weeks.
I actually do think Grock is a really
big quality of life upgrade just for the
speed.
Enemy count. Tower count.
Hang on. I I need to like actually
end round
time round.
placement slots.
Okay, cool. So, what are we doing here?
Site buildable TD num placement slots.
And what do we have after this? We've
got bins. Enemy progress bins.
Okay, we have water
or high water mark
ammo.
I can't tell if this is normalizing
everything.
Yeah, I can't tell if this normalizes
everything or not.
Okay. Yeah, this is good actually. Look,
do you see? He's actually he's fixed
this. This is good. So he added them
wrong, but then he
washes
Yeah, you're just going to go through
the list of
enemies.
Yeah. So, he is doing the spawns in a
loop, so that'll be slow.
But why do we have a million constants,
but then we also hardcode? Like I don't
really mind the hard coding to be fair.
If the numbers get used in one place,
you can just [ __ ] hard code them.
It's fine.
Oh, I guess we have Yeah, this is just
like the different rounds.
Linear wave.
Yeah. So definitely like the spawning
order if you just did them all at once
and maybe even off like spawn them off
screen if you have to um it'll be way
better than having to like go through
the list every time. Obviously there
more ways you can do it. That's just the
simplest one I can think of off hand.
ED prepare wave.
Yeah, just tons and tons of these little
methods.
Cash.
I think this is like the balloons thing,
right? Where like the enemy goes down a
tier or whatever. That's fine.
Add projectile.
I'm curious to see how you do this. So,
you add it to this pool.
Yeah, this is again
earn C99 strruct
impact
C9 like ststruct initializer please
by damage. some of this. I can't tell if
this is defensive actually off hand. Um,
apply damage.
What are we doing here?
Holy
crap.
Yeah.
is
I don't even know
nanas
my Butter
ED update projectiles
I'm pretty sure you can literally just
skip having to update projectiles, which
is kind of funny. Like for this type of
a game, you know when it's going to hit,
right?
That's a little sim trick right there.
just like there's just like bleeding
little bits of code everywhere, man.
log episode. Okay, I think this looks
like this is done correctly.
This doesn't need to be strct
initializer syntax.
Okay, we have invalid action.
Wait.
At least this chunk of the code makes
some sense. Yep.
And okay, cool. So, it's actually only
like 1,600 lines and then
600 lines of rendering.
I don't really like nesting str.
I I don't like nested trucks, man. I
just don't
This stuff is mostly fine. Loading code
is fine.
Finish.
Yeah, it's generally this is fine.
Client animation.
How do we do animation systems? Just PGs
maybe.
two links and
um I thought that there is one of those
in puffer already man. I guess if you
have better code or something.
I could have sworn there was one of
those.
It's weird because what I It's very
weird to me when stuff like functions
don't do what they're named.
Like this says render, but it actually
just returns a point. It doesn't even
like render it.
Render projectile. This doesn't even
render it. This just does a basic
transform
and copies your data. Again, by the way,
I don't know why we're marking
everything static as well. We have
static con is keyword bloat.
It's another thing I always forget about
people just keyword bloating everything.
Okay,
what do you want to bet that we have uh
we get the if thing is client not null
on the free?
See, this actually starts to look pretty
reasonable.
Yeah, this is just like decentish
procedural drawing code with too many
helpers and things split out, right?
Yep. Decentish procedural drawing code.
Basically, there's not too much for me
to say here.
Could definitely be less nasty.
And it looks like we don't have this one
thing, so that's good.
Well, the thing is, Liberty, it's not
like it's not like all I ever do is
complain about code style, but the thing
is
when there's this many things on the
code style, like that's going to be the
majority of what I look at, right? If
you submit to me something that is
already like good clean code and then
you have questions for me like on hey am
I modeling this correctly um do you
think I could like is there a way that I
could do this portion of the sim more
efficiently right like then we can go
into details right but the thing is you
have to pass the beginner level like
stuff being done correct before you get
to the advanced stuff cuz there are a
million places here where there I could
improve performance and shorten the code
and simplify things and make it easier
to model, right? And this is just true
of most of the PRs that I get, and it's
going to be true as well, especially if
you're like a new contributor and you do
something that's more than a a very
simple EN. This is a medium complexity N
for reference. This is not a trivial
env. um
like you're going to end up with stuff
like this, particularly if you're not
used to this style of programming, but
the goal is that you learn a lot from
your first Enver 2PR and you can take
that wherever you want, right? That
knowledge is going to just make you a
much better programmer, but then also uh
it's going to let you do much larger
projects in and around Puffer if you're
interested in continuing to do that.
It's from Muffin.
I think hard hard work went into this.
Yeah, I think so as well. I think so as
well. So I mean like you say uh the
intent is not just that he reads the
comments and sees me being very harsh,
right? The intent is that he sees the
full code review and learns a bunch of
stuff. If you watch the one from Tim as
well, like Tim learned a huge amount of
stuff from my review of Soabon and we
actually use Soabon quite heavily now as
a research and ended up being very very
useful.
Um
I think generally like
let me add some comments. Let me add one
other thing at the top
of uh of this
voice to text instead of typing. I like
typing.
I'm a better writer than I am a speaker,
so I'd rather write.
Bon review. I don't know. Kvert.
Somebody could tag it. It's on YouTube,
I'm sure.
Warrior CS school.
Yeah, you really do learn a lot from
this type of thing. It's not taught in
school. I am going to release a stupid
skillmd file at some point that will
like at least let people that are
heavily llming stuff not make a giga
giga mess of things. I might even try it
out on this end just to see how much
code we can cut. This is still a really
cool env and we're going to use this
right. So it'll be up to Muffin whether
he wants to take all the feedback and
try to clean stuff up which if he has
the time I he'll learn a ton by doing
that if he does. Um, you'll definitely
learn a ton a ton by doing that.
Can you do a fun visual memory puzzle
and you'd find it? Oh, how fast? Uh, I
think I can max like 80 to 90 WPM. I'm
not crazy fast.
In fact, when I was um I was actually
such a slow typer when I was first
learning to use a computer when I was
younger that like people thought I was
just not going to be able to use one at
all because I could type like 8 WPM when
like children could typically type 20 to
30. It just didn't click for me. I
actually mostly learned how to type
playing MMOs like chatting with my
friends on uh like DOUS and whatever
else.
It's not one of those typing tests.
Oh, haven't I haven't I done these?
Oh, the visual memory puzzle. I'm not
good at that.
Yeah, I'm not, dude. I'm not good at
these things like at all.
I don't claim to be a genius. I just
claim that everybody else [ __ ]
everything up somehow.
Is it this one? The sequence memory
thing. Oh, visual remember. This is the
chimp test, right?
Oh, and it gets bigger.
Great.
And it does like some weird pattern.
here. No, I forget something like that.
[ __ ]
Yeah, that's it.
That's all I got.
Oops, I misclicked that one. Uh, but
this now I forget.
Not great.
Not great at all.
you perform better than the world chess
champion.
I mean, the thing is these tests just
aren't really indicative of anything.
Nine [laughter]
That's funny.
These tests just are not indicative of
stuff as all.
Oh [ __ ] Did I
Huh?
That's not how you spell defense, is it?
Am I more No, I'm an idiot. It is. That
That is right, isn't it? Wait. Defense.
Oh, it's British. Okay,
it's British. Cool.
It is. It's It's just the Yeah. Okay.
Okay, 400k. The end is slowish, right?
It's 50 some odd K. Uh, we don't have
stats coming out yet, which is bad.
The IQ conversations are just always
dumb, man. Always dumb.
Like that [ __ ] does not matter. There.
Like I think at best a lot of the
standard tests can tell if you're a
[ __ ] but that's about it.
Of a bowl of what?
All right. All right. Let's not make fun
of our UK friends too much. They're
already dying of heatwave and no AC.
>> Look, don't piss off Finn too much, all
right? He's in the UK and he builds the
awesome drone sim.
27C. Isn't that like annoyingly hot?
Like 90° or something.
Okay. You cannot possibly give us all of
those. Like y'all you people in the
other countries are getting real fat,
too. Laziness as hell no. Uh
stupid. That's everywhere.
Cactuses. Yeah, we got some cactuses in
Texas, I guess. I I have no excuse for
McDonald's.
Uh we don't do politics on this stream,
so we're not commenting on that.
Uh, the college thing is ridiculous.
Yes, but it's more so the fact that they
don't actually teach you things rather
than they charge you a lot. The
healthcare is actually really, really
good. Private healthcare. Our food kicks
ass. Excuse me. We have this whole
southern region. Thank you very much.
Uh, music I'll give you, but unless
you're from like the Netherlands or
something, you kind of don't have a leg
to stand on. And our units are fine.
[ __ ] you. Put that in bullets per eagle
for me.
[laughter]
So there you go.
Oh, hang on. It's now at the very end.
It's like gotten us H. That's weird.
Yeah, super weird.
How are we doing on stream here? How
long have I been live?
We've been live for
almost four hours.
The funny thing that people don't get
about a lot of our units is they're like
colloquial units, right? Like a
tablespoon is a perfectly reasonable
unit to use when you're cooking cuz you
grab a spoonful of it and that's the
amount that you need,
I maintain that Fahrenheit is reasonable
for everyday use as well. 100 is very
hot. Zero is very cold.
they're colloquial units. They're not
good for precise stuff.
What's a tall person about six feet?
[laughter]
Like the granularity is about what you
would use for common use. It's like
about what you'd want for common use.
I mean, it was some dude's foot
originally probably, right?
But what's it matter? It's arbitrary.
Like, why is a meter a meter
So, it's pretty dumb. One foot is about
two cheeseburgers indeed.
Yeah, I agree. You should not be using
them forge, right?
I mean, to be fair, if you really wanted
to, right, you could just like pick one
of them and then just write, you know,
um,
like, you know, 1 ft or something.
You could very easily just apply power
of 10 prefixes to everything if you
wanted to.
You just change the base reference unit.
Like the other units are not meant for
precise anything. their colloquial
units.
all you people saying um all you people
like who think you're very scientific go
around saying that you weigh like 80
kilos or whatever
not a unit of weight.
So, realistically, the conclusion to
this is we're all a bunch of dumb asses
anyways, so who gives a [ __ ] [laughter]
Is that going to screw up breakout? It
shouldn't, right?
Thought we got rid of this weird
problem.
Really slow.
Why are we at 70k SPS? Actually, that
makes no sense.
Uh, we're going to see if it's an Eval
bug. Hang on.
What is this?
Ooh, that's really nice looking.
That's really cool.
See
action row by size of precision t.
Uh-huh.
That would break things.
We'll fix that real quick.
Oh, nice. Yeah. Yeah. So, this still
works.
Do tower defense.
And tower defense is just going to be
slow because the massive ass action
space, right?
So, massive action space has this thing
super slow, but that's a modeling
problem.
That's a modeling problem more than
anything. You can't have action action
spaces be that big.
You bleed all of your PF.
This thing should be much faster.
You bleed all your PF from this.
It does train.
Better than before, though.
Uh, we'll call that for now. I think
this is fine.
All right. So, we got um couple
different things PR in today.
We got Volo,
we got
Muffins to power defense PR
that I promised. I'm getting tired
though. I've really I've been reviewing
like [ __ ] tons of code and [ __ ] tons of
specifically LLM code all week. It's
kind of been exhausting.
Um I think that I am I'm happy with
where this is like for this week of
progress.
I mean
that's pretty good, right?
There's still a few things to clean up.
We have some algorithmic things to test.
Not completely ready for release.
Obviously, we have lots of M's to test,
but that's pretty good.
I think here's what I'm going to do. I'm
going to go use the restroom real quick
and then grab a drink. And it's Friday,
so why don't I just stream a little bit
of Net Hack. You know, we do a little
bit of Net Hack. Hopefully, I don't
screw up my current run.
And um I'm trying to learn more about
that game because Finn still is working
on that as his big project. And net hack
is one of those tasks that just really
scales. So if we can put a big number up
on net hack, I'll be very excited.
Skill dock.
Uh I don't have the energy for it at
this mo at the moment, Jess. I really
have just been grinding this all week. I
mean, let me think. How hard would it
be?
It's not going to be just making it
Jess. Like I think I'm gonna like have
to try that thing out multiple versions
of it on an end. Like I'll probably
write multiple versions of it and then
compare them like the code produced from
them like with a refactor of something
like the tower defense an and we'll see
what produces better code.
I'm not streaming Slay the Spire.
I do have that game. I played it a
couple times. I'll be right back though.
Let me use a restroom real quick and
then we'll see. All right, I'll be right
back. Oh yeah, for anybody who's new
around here, Star Puffer on GitHub. It
helps us out a lot.
it was good work today.
Good work.
It's still crazy to look at about a
third of the codes in the core here on
on Puffarel.
got 2K of algorithms and then
visualization here,
sweeps here and then the shared plumbing
for or shared config stuff here. Our
standalone CPU eval here and then just
our NV API which is uh that's bloated.
That's just including loading the puffer
fish which we'll fix that up. Not bad at
all.
probably will be able to fix vendor up
as well. Okay, so let's do
Or I can just change this text here.
We'll just do net hack break.
It's fine.
This is
a super deep simulation game.
Okay. Yeah. Good. There we are.
So,
let me remember what I was doing.
I got the
luck stone from the bottom of the mines
yesterday.
Uh I don't believe I know what it is
though.
Yeah. So, we have two uncursed gray
stones.
I have the blessed unicorn horn. I got
to remember that I have that.
What I'm currently trying to figure out
how to do is how we get our luck stone
to be blessed.
I think that is the main
keep some identified items in inventory.
Let me think here. So we have
we have the ability to bless.
plus scroll of identify
will identify more than one item. So
at least one chosen item
on its beatitude.
So I think that we just want to read
this scroll
and then this is the vast corp whatever
scroll.
So I think what we do is we do read oops
read
and then
uncursed Greystone
B
and then D.
Okay, this is an identify scroll. So we
I B is an uncursed lux scroll a lux
stone.
Okay.
How do we apply this holy water?
Uh I also
I let
I am running low on food.
I think it is worth going back just to
make sure that I did make the holy
water.
We'll do this in as few moves as
possible.
I'm just going to drop this.
And we're going to do
Okay. So now what we do is we just want
B, D, D.
Okay, nice.
So, before I forget,
we have a blessed clear potion,
which is going to be holy water.
Dipping
uncursed potions of water
using up the potion that was dipped into
Oh, hang on.
Dipping uncursed potions of water into
holy. So, if you have a little holy
water, you can make more holy water.
Basically,
it is generally pretty easy though for
us to get more holy water.
if I can get one more potion,
right?
I I should get one more potion, I think.
Let's see. I have money.
I don't really care what potions there
are here.
As long as I can get a murky potion,
I think that's fine, right?
Uh, do we have any other exclamation
marks? We do not.
I'd have to go there and back. I think
it's still fine, though. I think I think
that's worth doing just so that I don't
use up my
my holy water, right?
Cuz I really only need to bless one
thing.
This is like so incredibly complicated,
though. Oh, yeah. Drop my pickaxe. Drop.
Um,
where's my pickaxe? W.
Okay, so this guy's fine with me now.
That's an expensive potion.
Um, do I need money for anything? I
mean, realistically, I can farm as much
money as I
as I want, can't I?
Uh, I could have just screwed myself
over though if it's a Yeti. That's a
yellow light. Um.
Boom.
Do these things explode?
They do, right?
I can just put a blindfold on.
Okay,
let's just wear
a uncursed blindfold. G.
I mean, there's just so much stuff,
right, in this game that's going to be
hard to learn for an agent.
Okay. What? Uh, that's a crocodile.
I
should be fine.
Crocodile corpse. Can I eat that?
fireproof pair of low boots.
That's cool. I don't have a polymorph. I
think I just tin it.
Let's just apply
my tinning kit.
Now I have a tin of crocodile meat.
That gives me a little buffer of food.
Did I get my pickups back? I believe I
did.
Yes, I did. Okay. So, all I need to do
now is I just need to drop.
Okay. So, now I know
this potion is uncursed.
So, we're going to do dip. No, dip.
I want to dip this potion
into
dipping.
Why did that not produce more holy
water?
Is the wiki wrong? Dipping unp potions
of Oh, I didn't dilute it. I'm a [ __ ]
Yeah. So, I just blessed this random
potion.
Ah,
that was really stupid. I did it wrong.
Okay, no big deal. I just have to go
down a couple levels and find
I just have to go find some potions is
all. Right.
So, hang on. Let's see if I'm going to
Let's wear
Oops.
Drop.
We can drop this. This this
uh we can drop
this.
IP
going to drop all these gems in here.
What other things do we have?
Hopefully
this is enough.
Hopefully I've dropped enough things
that
Oh, wait. Is this a potion over here?
That's a potion. I'm dumb.
So, as long as this is not
I can't dip it here,
but as long as I can dilute this potion,
we'll take this.
All I have to do is go find a a fountain
or two to dip this into.
I'm going to be on the lookout for some
more potions as well.
Uh I'd like to create a few blessed
scrolls of identify.
See what do we have in here?
We have some corpses.
Corpses. Yeah. So, we're fine. We just
we don't care about any of this.
Okay, so now
we can just go down to the main
main dungeon level.
And
what else?
Is this a fountain over there? Is this a
sink?
Sink.
Sink. Okay, so that does not help us
at all.
We're going to
I actually want to wear the blindfold,
don't I?
So, let's just wear
a blindfold. See, this is actually very
nice because now
And let's throw this spear
at this water nymph.
I'm going to have to chase this annoying
thing down. I'm sure
you kill the water nymph.
Cool. So, we have a dagger, a chest, and
a
looking glass. Um,
okay. So, let's open.
Okay, the chest is empty.
Let's take the dagger. What's a looking
glass good for? Actually,
This is
Medusa.
Okay, so you do want one of these. Are
these heavy?
Not particularly heavy.
I think we will take this.
I We probably will get another one, but
let's take these two for now.
We'll take my spear.
Oops. Wield. I did the wrong thing.
I want to wield
Then we wear g
lizard corpse. I do these gives you um
hallucination.
Okay. So, you definitely you want one of
these to cure stoning though. I think
that a unicorn horn does this as well,
doesn't it?
not bad.
We'll take this for now.
And we just go down here.
I've learned that from playing this it
this is not a game that you play
quickly.
Um
I don't see anything on this floor and I
actually don't want to be wearing
a blindfold
cuz I can't really see items
like new items
if I am doing this.
So we go downstairs here.
Now,
this was I already used this fountain
up. There was a fountain there.
I could probably search
fuse potion. Okay,
I'd like that potion. Thank you.
This is the oracle level.
That is
a brilliant blue potion.
And we have lots of fountains.
I don't know.
I'm going to look up whether there's
specifically a problem if you mess up.
Let's put this blindfold on real quick.
Nothing here but the oracle. Right.
I'll keep this. Oh, and this D. I'll uh
I'll keep this on for a second.
A chickatress suddenly appears.
Chickatress.
What is that?
A passive attack that causes instant
stoning on Kin.
Okay.
Passive attack
automatically used in retaliation to a
melee attack.
Yeah. So, we do not want to mess with
this thing basically.
This is a C.
Basically, you just get away from this
thing because it's not particularly
fast.
Uh, it said it suddenly appears. Oh,
it's way over there. Okay, cool.
An owl bear appears close by.
I'm not too concerned about an owl bear.
Um, you're beginning to feel hungry.
I should be okay for a little bit.
Let's just get this potion.
Let's just remove
the blindfold.
Should be G.
Okay.
Uh, I can throw a few things.
Boom.
Why do we have two?
Okay, we have two things here.
and I kill the owl bear.
Uh, let's wear my blindfold.
Hey, and now owl bear. Can I eat this
thing?
Okay.
Uh, I'm in a very bad spot here.
And I dig into the Oracle room.
think I can. I just realized. So, I can
wield
pickaxe.
Okay, now let's wield my spear.
Now, let's see if there's anything with
the Oracle room fountains.
The rooms outside of the oracle five
monsters. Okay.
This does not seem to have anything
wrong with the uh the fountain.
dip for Excalibur.
Obtain a long sword.
Well, I still have not seen a long
sword.
diluting these potions
for some holy water is going to be the
most useful thing.
I really just need
I'm trying to think how many of these I
would like.
Two.
Two or three potions for now would be
enough.
Am I wearing this blindfold still? Yes.
Remove the blindfold.
Um, let's very quickly dip
my puse potion
into the fountain.
Let's do it again. Dip.
Pus potion into the fountain.
Okay.
Uh that's not holy water.
That is unfortunately
not holy water. That's just normal
water.
I messed up the calling before. I can
fix that. But let's just dip.
Feeling of loss comes over you. That
seems bad.
Okay, that's nothing.
If it's So now we know it's uncursed.
Whatever.
Yep.
Okay,
this fountain dries up.
I kill this water nymph.
Uh, this one I can take
I can take an emerald potion,
which is very nice.
And then I can dip
You feel a sudden shell to make sure we
have not screwed anything.
No effect.
You see how slow this game is, right?
Like
so much information to take into account
here.
Okay,
I think one more step.
Uh, you
dip
you.
Okay, cool.
Now we have a bunch of water. This is
not holy water. So, we're going to call
I O
uh water.
That's weird. I got to figure that out.
Uh I don't want to mess around here cuz
I need to
Okay, the cockatric is not anywhere near
me, so I'm fine. Is this just a dog?
Peaceful little dog.
It's fine.
We have plenty of water.
You should be fed.
Uh, that's a pancake.
I think it's probably rotten or
whatever, but I don't know if it can be.
But anyways, we're just going to go
upstairs
and let's go back to the
altar.
Uh, praying too often would be
very bad. I don't know how many turns
it's been since I have prayed.
I think it's not enough. Most likely
probably do a couple of things first
mold and an oil lamp.
Let's take Actually,
we're fine.
Okay.
This is why I should be writing down the
last time I prayed.
This is the nomish mines.
Get a job at train street.
No, thank you. That does not sound fun.
Enter name that.
Okay.
My guy, this might shock you.
I don't actually want a Lambo,
like at all.
Lo and behold, people have different
motivations.
Um,
no. I did a whole bunch of cool uh RL
work this week and it's Friday evening,
so I'm taking a little net hack break at
the end of my stream here.
Worth noting that we're actively using
this game as one of our um training
tasks. So this is partially for fun and
partially to understand
this better.
Um, I generally want to develop cool
sci-fi tech that improves the world in
some way.
I sure as hell want to be comfortable,
but I don't really have any use for
[ __ ] Lambo.
What is this? A cursed silver ring.
We can uncurse it.
We can uncurse that for sure.
When is the last time I prayed?
I'm streaming. I can actually check.
I can actually just chat, can't I? Hang
on.
Uh, let's just play this.
Okay, this is right.
Did you see my turn counter somewhere
here?
13974.
There we are.
Problems help to solve actual problems.
Well, um, if you like breakout, I guess
would be the example of a kind of
trivial problem. Yes, it does. Uh, Net
Hack is not a trivial problem. Like
solving this [ __ ] is way harder than
solving basically any other useful like
any other task that you would consider
to be actually useful.
So people just have um yes and no, but
often times people have a a wrong
definition of complexity.
Am I wearing a blindfold? Yes, I am.
Let's drop
drop this
and we'll drop Y Mr.
UVP.
Okay, so we have four uncurs potions.
C D E F
uh there isn't a good formal definition
of complexity. Honestly, there are a lot
of things that indicate complexity,
but you don't have to you don't have to
have a precise way to draw the line in
the sand to note that other people have
drawn it in a way that's
counterproductive.
Okay, so we have four uncursed potions
called holy water
all
I
name
doesn't it doesn't let me unname these
for some reason
I guess the next best thing will be to
like name
Uh V or I
V water.
Just water. Okay.
It's somewhat annoying that I I kind of
just have to go do some stuff.
Okay. Realistically, what do I want to
do here? Um, so scrolls would be nice,
right?
What do we have here? So, we have
looking glass, towel, chest, candles,
a mimic.
We know what the uh the identify scroll
is now.
And candles.
You do need candles, don't you?
But you need candles.
You need candles way later.
Okay, let's let's just go. I think let's
just go away, right?
robe. Yeah, I'm I'm wearing all all the
things I need
and I'm wearing invisibility.
So, I don't know what is going to be
next.
If we get into trouble,
I might regret this, but
all I need I do need another alter at
some point, but we will have to come
back,
but I don't want to get smited. I think
that would be
incredibly stupid.
Procedure of getting a PhD.
Well, typically you've already done
quite a bit of research before you start
one. Um, you take a few mandatory
classes, which if you're at all
competent, won't particularly teach you
much of anything new. And then you spend
four to six years doing research,
publishing papers on a specific area.
course. Lizard corpse.
Why? Why do I have auto pickup on?
Um, pick up.
That should not be on. I don't know how
that got set on. That's very weird.
That's That's very concerning. That's
pretty much it.
just woke up to stream
one single paper. No, lots of papers. U
my if you want to get an idea, my thesis
is on J Suarez 5341.github.io
or whatever. Likeund and some odd like
60 pages or something worth of papers
all stapled together.
It's quite a lot of work. Some fields it
is literally one big paper but those are
typically fields where the experiments
take way
longer you know physical sciences
in CS you'll typically have anywhere
well from 3 to like 10 depending on your
area.
Let's just wear this blindfold again.
This is not really ideal for finding
items, but I don't really want to run
anything into anything
nasty just yet.
This
ocatress.
Uh there's probably a door here, but
it's going to be quicker to just wield
W.
Then we can just wield
I need a better weapon.
I definitely need a better weapon. But
the thing is, I could go just find a
long sword down here. And if I find a
long sword
that just solves all of my problems.
I do have an uncursed pancake. Oh, look
at that. So, we have
potions, a soldier ant,
but let's do this. And let's just remove
this blindfold.
Let's throw this
build your ant corpse. Is that safe to
eat?
When was that recorded? Several like
couple weeks. Three, four weeks ago, I
think now. I don't know. Not that long.
Uh, I think I do have
I think I do have poison resistance, but
just to be sure cuz I don't really
remember, let's just apply
this tinning kit
and let's eat
this tin.
How am I still hungry?
Okay. So, we we have some potions here.
Uh, we can
we can get this potion here, this dagger
potentially.
Now, I guess the question is how quickly
do we want to descend here?
I think we definitely put this blindfold
on
so that we can
Now let's just do remove this.
Yeah. So now we have
a little bit more ability to see things.
What's this? Jelly. We don't care about
this.
Okay. I know we're hungry here because
of the the food poison or the uh the
rotten food. Okay. So, what can I eat?
Okay, we definitely need to be on the
lookout for more things because we need
food and
that is going to be a problem. No, man.
How am I beginning to feel hungry again?
I just ate.
Right.
I just ate. Right. This is how I like this is how I lost my
This is how I like this is how I lost my
previous run.
There's no conceivable reason I should
just be immediately hungry again.
Trackmania pretty hard.
There's no conceivable reason I should
be hungry again immediately.
I know I don't have a ring of
rightious hunger.
It's definitely not just you're burdened
or whatever. I don't have a burdened
indicator.
Yes, there is a hidden food metric, but
that should have been a large meal.
And I'm immediately hungry again.
Um, this is
Wait, why does this have a level up on
it?
Wait. Huh?
There are two different.
Have I been here?
Oh, this is so
actually. Hang on. Is there food in
here?
Last wand. Food ration.
Two food rations. Food ration. Okay.
Uh, we can take this.
I got hungry enough that the uh the
lizard corpse I guess looked like a um
everything looks like food or something.
Okay, this is good. I already have a
ring of levitation,
so we'll take these food rations.
Believe those were uncursed, so we're
probably fine for now.
Am I wearing I'm not wearing my
blindfold, right?
No, I'm not wearing the
Where's the blindfold? Actually, wait.
Oh, yeah. I'm not wearing the blindfold.
Cool.
Go get this pus potion.
What on earth is this? A gold.
You can eat the lizards. They caused
some confusion and such.
They drop a bunch of gold.
Cool.
Yay! Money.
Okay. Older ant corpse dart. Uncursed
food rations. Lovely.
Nope. Don't step on that.
there's a crocodile there.
Other than that, we are we are good.
Um, so I can remove the blindfold.
And now we're basically
just exploring
Entering a water square will cause you
to fall in.
So let's just remove
X
and that's where
Right.
Levitation ring.
I don't have blindfold on.
What is this wall?
Let's wield
wield W.
Giant zombie
with some chests.
Cool.
You move over the moat.
Giant zombie.
How strong is that?
Not that strong.
They grant giant. They still grant
strength increases.
Uh, we go chill out. We just go hang out
here for a second.
What is this?
An ape.
Not what I want to see.
Uh, let's throw
this.
Oh, ouch. Okay. So, let's remove
this ring.
And then let's throw
this.
And I think that's all I have to throw.
There's a crocodile in the way. That's
weird.
We're going to go get dinner soon as
well.
Okay, we finish eating this thing.
Pick this up. Eat.
Now I'm satiated. Good.
Okay.
Not eat the ape corpse. That would be
bad.
Just going to let myself heal back up
naturally.
Takes quite a few turns, but that's
okay.
We're going to see what we can loot from
this
island. And I think that'll be what we
do for today.
Unless an ogre happens to come over here
to
bother me.
Let's just wear
uncurs ring of levitation.
And we just say goodbye to this ogre.
Um, I don't really like waiting here
over the water,
but
I really do want to just get my health
back up, too.
Boom boom boom.
Okay, nice.
Now we can remove Let's not forget to
take this thing. Put this thing back on.
A giant corpse and a chest.
I can eat this thing.
Let me see. Can I tin it or no?
let's just tin this for now. Let's just
apply
Um,
is this more useful than a pickaxe?
Okay, we definitely want this.
Okay, so we have to drop something.
Um,
okay. Potion of oil. Cool.
Abracadabra
Use slime molds. Don't really care about
that.
So
Um, I I think I'm just going to drop
this 10. So, let's just drop
this.
Okay.
Now, this thing that I really wanted to
be careful of, right, is wearing
put the ring of levitation back on.
Okay. Okay. So, now
we have
Yeah. Let's go this way. It's the stupid
ogre. It doesn't tread like
Okay, we have an ogre corpse, an ape
corpse, and I don't know why
this thing is here, but whatever.
enough adventuring on this floor for my
liking.
Okay. What is this?
This is a Roth and a gecko.
Let's just wear or uh remove this
growth. I can take care of no problem.
Uh let's take
let's take this ring off. This is just
costing me
energy.
Oh, there's something over there.
What is this
statue?
Uh, and a scroll.
And I really don't have
that much inventory.
Warf lady
turns into a large cat. Lovely.
Let's see. It's probably worth grabbing
that. Why are the scrolls backwards?
Uh, they're not backwards.
They're just like they're scrambled up.
Like they don't actually mean anything.
You have to identify them.
I don't know what this is.
A jeweled wand. A tripe ration.
Okay.
No, let's not eat ogre corpse.
We're probably we're fine for now.
Um,
the safest move right now would just be
to go back up to mine town. As annoying
as that is, I have lots of uncursed food
rations.
Like what even is this? Right. That's
the quant. That's a quantum. Yeah,
that's we don't want to be dealing with
that. I need I need things. Thank you.
Something crashed through. Yeah. So
that's Yeah, we don't want to deal with
any of that crap right now, right?
I think we just want to
I can check this out real quick.
What's this? An engraving? Yeah, we we
don't want any of this. We just want to
go back
blindfold.
Stuff won't surprise me.
I already beat Soon on this uh this
level. Soon's done. Amulative reflection
right there.
Emulative reflections mine.
The stone giant appears next to you.
That sounds really dumb. Let's not deal
with that [ __ ] Okay, so we still
have
we have some fountains here. I really
don't want to deal with that
cockatress or cockat whatever the [ __ ]
it is. Um,
Yeah, that's you have to either drop
everything.
You can dip it. This consumes the water.
I think that we're just going to do
that.
I can see this cockatrist thing. What
the hell is that?
It's just a bat. Um,
Oh, you can't do that.
Is it worth going around?
I think we'll just do this.
We'll see what the
Ocatris does. It's not going to me.
So, I think it's fine for the time
being.
This is just a dog
looking glass.
Okay, we can dip
lots of things here, right? So, let's
dip J.
I actually think I'm going to dip this
other one.
Okay,
two uncurs scrolls.
Do I need to dip any other potions?
I don't think so.
I'm going use.
And now we're going to juke the
cockatress.
Going to just juke around.
What's this? Red gem. Sure.
Oops.
We'll take that. Why not?
And again, we just go back up.
And yes, this is a lot of backtracking.
Very annoying. But
uh in my view,
this is
much better
than uh than dealing with
random stupid [ __ ] deaths.
and now we should start feeling sort of
safe.
It's net hack, so you're never really
safe, but
Oh, there is literally an altar here
actually.
Can I just do it right here or is this
an unaligned altar?
Neutral alter. Okay, let's do um let's
just wear it on Let's Let's go back to
Mine Town. It's fine.
Yeah, like this. Okay, cool. So,
now I really do wish I could find a
freaking long sword, you know? Dingo
suddenly appears,
but let's just go.
we're going to just drop
this unfurskish helm.
Now let's just drop.
Prayer will bless any potions of water
on that altar square. So successful
prayer.
And then I want to drop the
Okay. So now because those are not holy
water, those are just water. That that
almost could screw me up there.
Now
I want to pray.
Some of the potions glow light blue for
a moment. Very good.
Now we can pick up all of this
and we can Oops.
name
be
space
holy water. Cool.
Okay. So now we have this done.
What is this thing here? The dingo.
Okay.
Now we can dip a lux stone,
right? Dip
Oh, I left this on the ground. That was
very, very bad.
Let me take this and let's take this
scroll.
Okay, so this is what we're going to do
now.
We're going to dip
uncursed Luck Stone
into
this. Boom. Now it's blessed.
A blessed luck stone.
Very, very nice.
I believe there are a few other items
that we want to bless. Probably the
unicorn horn.
Now we have two uncursed, unlabeled
scrolls.
Um, how do we bless?
Okay, I think this works.
So I think what I can do is I can dip
uh this
into this
two blast unlabelled scrolls. Cool. So
now magic marker.
Where's my magic marker?
Uncursed magic marker.
I could bless it first.
I think I'm just going to do like this
first.
I'm going to write on J.
What type of scroll do you want to
write?
Think I can just type
identify
and I have a bless scroll of identify.
Very nice.
Okay, so
Last thing I want to figure out. I don't
want to mess this up.
So, let's read this.
We
really want to identify. Let's Let's
just take a look what we have in our
inventory.
We have a couple of wands
I mean, we have gems, but I don't think
that we care too much.
So, let's do
let's read the identify scroll.
What would you like to identify first?
Okay, cool.
So, I think
Did we put on various rings first? I
think we should.
And then we'll identify after
to see if anything pops out.
Okay, cool. So,
let us identify
a blessed scroll of
That's really [ __ ] It so it just
doesn't give it to me. That's annoying.
I didn't know it would do that.
Let's just write on this.
Now I know. I won't do that again.
So, first we'll identify this ring.
Uncursed ring of fire. And of course, my
bless scroll is only one thing. That's
so annoying.
Oh, no. No. We're good. We're good. We
have more. Cool.
We're good.
Uh, let's do ivory ring next.
Uncursed ring.
Let's do X.
Uncursed ring of hunger.
Oh, good thing we don't have that.
of hunger.
Wait, isn't that the good one?
No, this is bad.
So, I was wearing that at one point.
That's bad.
Uh, I have a plus two ring of increased
damage.
That looks really nice.
Okay, small damage bonus.
I mean, it's not bad.
So, we have a few things. I can just
like I don't want this.
I really should get one more, shouldn't
I?
Okay, let's just dip
dip.
We'll just do
this a
into this
and then we'll uh apply
We'll do this to a
identify.
We'll read this
and we want to identify W first.
Ring of Conflict.
That's actually really useful.
Okay. Um, can you uncurse
dip it into holy water. Okay, so this is
fine. So I think it is worth identifying
this cursed silver ring.
Okay, so that's not super. Yeah, that's
not going to be great. So we can just
drop
Yeah. So, that is very very nice.
Okay. I have
I've got some good stuff now.
I don't have a good weapon.
Is there a reliable way I can get a
damned long sword?
I could bless. If I could get a bless
scroll, maybe.
I think we're fine.
I think we literally just um
we go price ID.
Yeah. So, enchant weapon.
Oh, is a boon from a successful prayer.
That's also I think we're just kind of
fine. Honestly,
I don't have a good weapon yet.
Let me go figure out as well cuz I was
supposed to have stuff going on.
Oh, okay. I missed a bunch of stuff.
Um,
I gotta go. My bad.
Uh, I will see you all later, folks.